the first moment I am dying to ask you
about is the time in the courtroom where
Emily mutters guilty what what are you
keeping in mind performing a very key
like one-word line of dialogue right
there in order to make sure just her
convictions as far as why she did that
are on display and also just to make
sure that you you nail that line
properly I mean number one I was very
nervous it felt like such a delicate
moment and we worked on it a lot I had a
love health from from you know my scene
partner isn't Massey was right there
always and ten we tried it a few
different ways we tried it a few
different ways because I think the
amazing special thing about about Emily
is that like you're not always totally
sure what's going on because our journey
is very internal and I think that's
indicative of women of that time they
weren't really afforded the opportunity
to explore themselves or be vocal or
understand what's really going on for
them or not to be influenced and and I
think she's struggling so I think for me
I'm not sure if I'm totally understand
your question correctly but like for me
the experience of like embodying that
moment was accepting accepting her fate
because I think that's what she's doing
in that moment so so accepting her fate
but do you do you think that in that
particular beat she really felt guilty
no okay but yes this is like no yeah yes
and it's always no but yes you know it's
it was like she felt crushed so she can
is an amazing psychological moment where
someone has really actually kind of
convinced themselves because they don't
have any other option and that
devastating to me as an actor to like
wrap my head around